here are the nominees for best
documentary short subject
audible matt ogins and jeff mclean lead
me home pedro coss and john shank
the queen of basketball ben proudfoot
three songs for benazir elizabeth mirzae
and gulastan mirzai
when we were bullies jay rosenblatt
[Music]
and the oscar goes to
the queen of basketball
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thank you to the academy
uh to my fellow
nominees
uh to the new york times
to shaq to steph
madison wells dns and everybody who
helped make this film from breakwater
studios
if there is anyone out there
that still doubts
whether there's an audience for female
athletes
that still questions
whether those stories are
valuable or entertaining
or important
let this academy award be the answer
uh
lucy
lucy harris is not here tonight because
she passed away before this film was
nominated
lucy deserved better this recognition
came way too late women athletes deserve
better
but her family is here tonight so i'd
ask you to please give your recognition
to them
and one
one last thing
president biden bring britney griner
home
thank you long live the queen
thank you